that's right in a world of irony and
love for all things I am wearing a
Deadpool shirt while I'm talking about a
trailer for a DC movie because I'm not
at all so here's how this went down I
got home from Emerald City Comicon I
plopped on my couch I was like I've been
on my feet all weekend long I've had a
great time but I am feet and just gonna
check my Twitter relax and okay there's
a new trailer for Suicide Squad let's
get that camera up there is no rest for
the wicked
so this new Suicide Squad trailer is
actually a lot like the last Suicide
Squad trailer just with a new song but
they do have a say in the beginning with
this guys like what if Superman came
down decided to rip the roof off of the
White House and take the president who
would stop him behold our countermeasure
unless any of them has a mother named
Martha in which case I guess that's not
gonna work which is funny because
whatever you thought about Batman vs
Superman if you loved it awesome glad
you had a good time a lot of people were
disappointed in it and it's after Batman
vs Superman then they started filming
new scenes for the Suicide Squad and the
rumor is they did reshoot so it would
have more jokes it would be lighter and
then Jai Courtney said no that's not why
we're doing it of reshoots happen all
the time is no big deal and I tend to
think that he's probably telling the
truth just because there are a lot of
jokes in this trailer and I think that's
why this trailer came out there are a
lot of jokes in this trailer and I just
don't think that in the course of two
weeks they could react to Batman vs
Superman get a plan together get all the
actors back build the set again put them
on location again all those departments
all those cogs are a lot of cogs that
come together for something like that
have them film all the jokes have it all
be done and put it in trailer what two
weeks after Batman vs Superman came out
and they know it didn't happen like that
and that's what I like about this and I
really hope they commit to the tone
where it's like it's it's ridiculous
with a bunch of criminals who are being
controlled by the government who are
inevitably gonna be like oh we just
don't want that anymore I do wonder
about their situation though because the
trailer shows us that helicopter that's
tumbling out of the air that actually
has a Suicide Squad in it so I think
what happens is that helicopter gets
shot down while they're going into
something a mission or something and
they get cut off from communication from
Argus so basically Rick Flagg is the
only thing they're keeping the Suicide
Squad in line and they're gonna be like
there's more of us than there are of you
we're actually pretty big and tough and
we have magic so yeah we're gonna do our
own thing
we're gonna have some chaos and fun I
still don't know what to make of the
Joker in this I don't know if the Joker
is the thing they have to go and try to
stop or if the Joker's a wild card who
sees them doing something he's like I'm
just gonna mess with them because that'd
probably be fun I hope is that a second
one honestly we see more batfleck in
this trailer that was smart of them to
put bat flick in the trailer because no
matter what anyone thought a Batman
versus Superman
everybody agreed on one thing and that
is Ben Affleck was pretty awesome
Suicide Squad is always look like a
great movie and I'm looking forward to
the Suicide Squad this trailer did not
sway me on that a little bummed out that
the trailers pretty much the same as the
last trailer just with a different song
I want to have fun with the DC Universe
I feel like this is the movie to do that
to end this though let's touch on this
right now how rad is Joker look right
there seriously it looks like straight
out of Scott Snyder's end game it's a
pretty rad piece of imagery right there
The Suicide Squad I'm looking forward to
it I am because not one of those people
was like alright there's that one movie
in that universe I didn't like now it's
all compromised forever different
director different crew different
strokes different folks
I think Suicide Squad might just be a
really good time so this is new Suicide
Squad trailer have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more